hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsenses.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i started to make youtube videos a
few months ago
where i mostly talk about the hot stocks
that do some crazy moves you know this
past few weeks
but also talk about the different
techniques that i like to use to do my
analysis and how pro traders are
actually working
so if you want to guys know about all
this stuff you are in the right place
today i want to talk about clvs guys
because this
is a hot stock let's get into it
[Music]
so very quickly guys so i'm doing some
analysis
so i did previously some stuff on the
wheat stocks amc
i like to discuss this one and clvs guys
uh so clvs is very interesting so they
have 40 percent of short interest
the reason is it's not in green what is
green is what is hot you know
it's because actually when you look at
the volumes it's not that big yet
guys all right the volumes are around
like 20 million it's something you know
there is nothing crazy for now it's been
trending
more like for the past year we have
around 20 million shares
trading a day which is around 200
million
uh us dollars so it's around 30 of the
total market capitalization
so it's not a lot compared to the other
stocks that sometimes reach 100 200
300 5 000 i'm going to talk about this
one very
soon uh just uh to compare tesla is for
example the same stuff all right but
tesla has only six percent of short
interest
clvs has 41 once again guys i want to
show you where i found my information
as i did in my previous videos i go on
market bid guys
and i cross check this data with
bloomberg because i'm a professional i'm
not using bloomberg for my videos
because i'm not allowed
but i can just cross check the data and
it's not exactly the same data but it's
very close
see and yes okay
you type here so you have a lot of
information the market cap is here
600 million and the short interest are
here guys you type here and you can see
41 as of 29th of jan all right so it's
not a very first that data
this was two weeks ago i'm gonna update
you when i see anything else on
bloomberg you don't have anything better
uh if you want to have something better
you need to pay a lot of money so maybe
i'm gonna you know do it for you guys
and subscribe to some stuff like this
and share with you the information for
now
i'm using this data this public data so
all right this was two weeks ago
so it's a lot guys forty percent of
short interest
it's a lot which makes it a potential
target with a very small market cap
below one billion
for those redditors wall street batters
people who hang out on twitter
so i also follow uh this guy zach
maurice guys
so he is the uh master guru of twitter
400
000 followers and uh you know so he's
talking about
a lot about which stocks that's why i
talked about it uh i don't see it here
guys but he talked about clds
all right so you can find uh some people
like ace ventura so of course it's not
the real one
i mean who knows buy dips not rips all
right which gave me to understand that
those who buy dips never lose money so
the goat zach maurice
saw the greatest of all time you know so
they are just you know
it's their master and this guy is
talking about clvs
so yeah let's do some technical analysis
guys because
i checked i didn't see any major news uh
so it's a firm that is basically
it's a medical firm so any news can come
at any time and of course it's
it can shake this market for now we have
a breakout guys
not retested yet all right the breakout
happened occurred at
the sixth level right let me put
the breakout level is always a nice
level to buy guys because it's usually
retested so you can do it different way
i advise you guys to go check my video
on the breakouts that i did three weeks
ago sorry or one month
where i explained how to trade breakouts
and basically you can put a support
level at the breakout level or
at the resistance that is actually a
downward sloping trend line that is
going to be just below
so and here you have the moving averages
look the 200 moving
a period moving average which is a very
good level dynamic
support or resistance level that is
moving with the stock
is now at this level so we broke on the
very short term guys
some people were asking me oh what is
happening clbs is going lower guys don't
panic all right we had a strong move up
uh that was uh you know 70 and now we
haven't really tested this level yet so
we are going there i think but don't
panic and here we had some consolidation
yes it could have gone higher
but it broke it on the downside and it
retested it and it got rejected
so here you can do some day trading just
put a stop loss right below
or just wait and when it retests you can
not sell the breakout as i say but sell
the retest even if you are
long all right but to stop your position
you can directly play the breakout
so now we broke this level uh we are
going lower so i think the next support
levels are here
6 30 5 so if it goes here guys it's a
beautiful opportunity we didn't have
this crazy moves up as we did on the
other stuff
this is you know a stock everybody is
talking about a small market cap
but the volume have not picked up yet we
are waiting for something we are waiting
for
the sparkle that is gonna uh put the
fire to everything
all right and we can have some you know
easily two three hundred percent moves
up guys i'm not saying this is gonna
happen i'm just saying the situation
looks beautiful all right so you can
take
profits here here
and here if you want you know so if you
buy
it here you can just take 150
uh take half of your profit and just
leave it uh
go higher if it wants to because once
again the market cap is very small guys
so if you know for example chile we had
10 billion u.s dollar trading in one
day if all this money and it's the same
guys you know that gonna
do this it's the same guys that did gme
15 billion
10 billion all right so this is they're
able to trade
10 20 billion if they all put the money
together that's
what all these guru are trying to do
they're trying to direct these people
in the same stock but if this 10 billion
go to clvs guys
it's gonna be 10 times more than the
market cap so let me just
assume it's going to be eight you know
it's 1 000
it's gonna be the big big big winner of
all the stuff
so of course it can go much much higher
guys come back to the technicals uh so
yeah you can buy at six
put more at 550 you know and build up
some long position here uh you can put a
stop loss below
like even here guys look you have one
more support so basically all this area
is full of support levels
you can put the stop loss at four so
don't put too much money into this if
you start buying here
you can lose 30 percent all right so you
can just lose 30
of your capital and you can just
increase the lower it goes the more you
buy
and once again if you average and you
buy at 550 guys it's like we're talking
about like you know crazy risk reward
ratios around like
a 10 you know you can lose 30 you can
make 300 so
guys i'm very bullish on this stuff so
that's it for me uh next
i'm gonna do sckt crazy stuff guys i
want to
show you what i found out here i'm gonna
do an update on tesla and then i'll see
what
uh hot stocks i'm gonna talk about so
that's it for me i hope you enjoyed this
video and if you want to know about my
other updates please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys